hello freak [ __ ] the last maybe the
last filled up maybe sex will be fate I
mean there was a book called started a
circle back to porn again there's a book
called porn nation and in it there was a
statistic that said 80% of kids under 18
boys would rather watch porn than have
sex with an actual woman what yes focus
group probably very specific group of
people who would agree to be interviewed
about you know whatever the same
[ __ ] I think women have to
masturbate in tubs only so but I mean
who knows fake boobs fake news you could
probably prefer cuz you're in control of
it if you have a VR woman who's gonna do
whatever you want you don't have to deal
with her afterwards and like talk about
like what are we yeah but that's half
the thrill yeah I have to throw you grow
up on fake women and anime Wow super
jerking off to cartoons guys you don't
understand like we watch Saturday
morning cartoons they are jerking off to
animated and women oh God
so why how many how many most of them
are jerking oh you've been more will you
look up in an animated like how many
people are yeah and I'm a poor man I'm a
boy I would say it's a very small number
which by the way a lot of the women in
real porn are more lifeless than the
animated by well they're they're weird
now because they couldn't fake asses
well it's like jean baudrillard 'he's
like theory of like simulacrum about
like how we prefer this simulation of
something to the original of something
when we can actually control it I think
Andy Warhol was onto that as well but
well isn't it bizarre that some men
prefer fake boobs yeah like they get why
don't why getting off to anime porn is
shorthand for supporting Donald Trump
weird connection Loren grizzly the name
Orsini
horse any oh this just happened to pop
up but what a bizarre [ __ ] title okay
let's let's see what she has to say
god dammit Forbes continuing for yeah
it's hilarious on Tuesday evening GOP
consultant Rick Wilson made Twitter
waves with look at that they have the
[ __ ] stock of Twitter right there
single men +0 50% 0.50 percent in that
hilarious
they showed Twitter and then they have
and when people reading Forbes all will
just talk at right next to know their
audience so weird waves with his claim
that Donald Trump supporters are mostly
single men who masturbate to either a
he's a GOP consultant to I think they're
right with this is an intentionally
incendiary statement that Wilson says he
made directly to troll Trump's followers
everybody's trolling everybody first of
all as any anime fan will let you know
it's called um clears throat hentai a
specific genre of x-rated Japanese
animated cartoons but what's interesting
is that in order to intentionally make
people angry Wilson targeted anime geeks
as his insult each tweet don't upset
them yeah they don't reply you I don't
know I can't I can compete with I feel
strongly that's I'm like okay I can
compete with the girl I've seen poor I
can't compete with cartoons yeah
cellulite it's it's I really don't want
to have that how many people how one
website is convincing people to pay for
cartoon porn
[Laughter]
whoa hold on a second among 18 to 34
year-old viewers cartoon and hentai are
the 13th and 17th most popular porn
searches and Millennials are 131 percent
more likely to search for anime than
older browsers this is what I'm saying
whoa you just blew my mind so can we see
what the other 12 porn categories are
above Saul gagging it's all gagging
while getting choked oh here we go
number one with a [ __ ] bullet Wow
lesbian and then teen and then let's not
brush past teen that's of awful yeah
that's horrifying
you're monsters I'd rather you watch
anime stepmom is ahead of milf wait whoa
and then squirt people are in the peen
people are in the squirt
they like the square they think it's
anything other than pink and then mom's
blue it's a mixture
well ice not really coming out of your
[ __ ] it's pee then when scientists
analyze it they go well it's not all
back we're gonna start go back to that
so it's interesting to me that stepmom
is above milf yeah it's very interesting
I want I don't want it I want a mom I
don't want to be you want to [ __ ] your
dad's well yeah that's what it is that
is that a weird like Freudian VNV thing
number one number one at the bottom
rather the least is public public is the
least searched anal is above a little
shocking lilo I know Eponine and how
many is above black which I think what's
the difference I'm so wrong for educated
people oh wait no one is really
important but wait why is why is
Japanese and Asian I know why they're
different kind of but do you see how
their different counties Asians way down
low people are way more into Japanese
than they are and so specifically
Japanese Asian to get like Vietnamese
Thai and people like nope nope nope not
aligned I want a girl with the kimono
yeah I guess a girl oh interesting to
the power thing yeah but I think
anything I say here is gonna be
misconstrued as not racist don't be
worried about that ah this is the age we
live in
okay what is the difference for you
evany in black I'm so sorry there is no
difference one of them is said by people
with education got it and the other one
is someone who just wants anonymous but
I'd imagine what's under those one's
gonna be classier than the other maybe
there's something socio lineal
search-term differences look at this
cosplay cosplay sorry I don't know turn
coming or [ __ ] costumes why would
you think cosplay is toilet I don't know
but I said it's so nonchalantly
footjob look at that what is the foot
fetish thing do you know oh I guess it's
like something happening when you were
young oh like some sort of isn't that
called cathexis
um
it's called imprinting yes sexual
imprint yeah right look at that yoga let
me see
yoga's in there right below the ball is
important these days I see a lot of sex
on yoga balls I do not feel sexy but a
gym is above yoga which is interesting
more people call the less fit yeah the
more people can relate like a girl doing
squats but what if she just watch wait
what's um yo V now that I heard that
pornstar Nellie Fitness I get the gym
porn joke
what is um emo like goth girls to
Morrissey yeah really
lot of crying T's tattoos like Suicide
Girl tech girl girl emo no sure that's
what they are why they call it emo
though suicide girl a generality I would
think emo bunch of margins I can't put
suicide on here then you're looking for
suicide port and that's that way
different thing then yeah that's not
real porn that's just crime what's that
guy who committed suicide Elliot
something another what the [ __ ] is
Elliott Smith was that his name Duncan
told me to listen to him I listen to him
Mike Duncan what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you it was like super depressing music
no wonder this guy stabbed himself wait
can you walk me through this so what is
dogging doggy sighs doggy or walking
boss says dogging dogging what the long
nipples is at the very bottom granny is
well above long nipples wait so it's
anonymous
Harry smoking with smoking where does
that wife swap so why is it negative
does this mean it's become less popular
this one is actually comparing
millennial searches to people or the
Nemesis Millennials are more in doll
this but this stuff is all new
Millennials never probably had the
opportunity to see granny
well there's granny porn that's more
prevalent now than ever before
what if you were a grant what if you
were a tea doing porn what does that
what is that that's a pitch that no
she's gonna die just wants a ride that
boat right into the rock
hit the throttle Wow
she's bobbing across the top of the
ocean yeah she sees the rock she doesn't
lit up at all
she's even close her eyes go back up
stop scrolling so much it's awesome no
teeth
Kim Kardashian is the most popular porn
star searched by Millennials is she a
porn star yeah she's got a porn tape oh
that's amazing
no the rest of that's me Khalifa who's
like a she's Khalifa's Lisa Ann who's
deep in her forties I believe good for
her that's a victory interesting
hey I don't know any of these people
Sasha Grey I feel like she's fallen and
off the I don't think she doesn't
anymore oh really she's I think she
retired her vagina in the towel yeah I
mean it's like a fighter they get enough
headshots no like I gotta step away I
said enough concussions
[Applause]
[Music]